now at the same time as the coronavirus
and the omicron variant is spreading
tomorrow is winter break ending for
clark county school district but the
excitement of getting back to class it's
tempered by that spread of omicron
bianca holmen breaks down what schools
are doing to try and prevent more cases
clark county school district students go
back to class on wednesday at the same
time coronavirus cases are surging
parents don't just have to worry about
covet but it's also fluent cold season
dr david de jon at the kirk cocorian
school of medicine at unlv says testing
is key to telling the difference the
best thing
for
parents to do with their kids is take
them to their physician or to the local
emergency department
where they'll have the capability to do
specific testing
and there are really excellent tests now
to try to differentiate some of these
infections
from one another los angeles unified
school district is requiring students
and staff to get tested before returning
to school i asked the clark county
education association if ccsd could do
something similar is there the capacity
to do those kind of measures in other
words test everybody before they come
back and i think there's there's a kind
of a delay in the roll out of additional
testing capacity i think that people are
experiencing school leaders say children
should stay at home if they test
positive for covid and call the
district's coven 19 hotline to help
protect students the district will
continue to use the r0 arc uvc system
and students and staff are still
required to wear masks i think the tools
are there
right
and
with the exception of not having enough
testing capacity right now but that's
that's around the corner
i think the tools are there it's all
about execution bianca holman live local
now